[Music]
last week i made a video about a
particular pipsqueak
a particular delinquent
a particular ruffian an individual a
fool
block-headed fool
who who's coming out and burning the
quran on a weekly basis
thinking that he's harming islam and the
muslims
thereby unfortunately for him i have to
say he has come out and done it again
let's take a look at the video of him
being aggressive and burning the quran
coming out of masajid
people trying a threatening behavior to
people
and come back and see
as you can see this fool thinks he's
getting something done he's achieving
something that the objective is being
i'll tell you what objective is being
met what objective is being met is that
you're actually helping us
raise money to establish islam and
muslims in norway in fact the video that
we've done last
80 000
euros were raised that's thanks to you
uh last thorns i wanted to thank you
personally
uh again you know that's 80 000 euros
you can get a lot with with that and as
i promised every time
you burn a quran that's a promise of
mine
yes and the promise of the muslim
community
was the promise of the muslim community
that every time
that you burn the quran there'll be 50
000 euros to your name that you'll be
yourself
the chief fundraiser thank you so much
last throne for fundraising by doing
antagonizing the muslims making the
muslims angry making the muslims give
charity in the last 10 nights of ramadan
which is what you're doing which is what
it is now
you're encouraging the muslims to do
this
but not only that but you've actually
come out you had the audacity you had
the bravery
to challenge me to a debate it's changed
muhammad hijab
to a debate no problem i accept the
debate i'll come down to norway let's
debate is islam true let's debate
anything you like
you can bring
whatever you want
and we'll have a discussion not just you
but that political leader in uh sweden
i'm one maybe when i'm done with you
i'll go you know it's only a
one-hour flight or something to sweden
enough deal with him as well but for now
what i will say is for the muslim
community as we promise to the people
that every time this man burns a quran
and he creates a ruckus in our community
and he creates some problems in our
community that you're going to yourself
last as a chief fundraising officer you
are going to now help us raise another
100 000 since we're now yes we're now in
the last 10 nights of ramadan
so this is the time for everybody
to go full throttle
to honestly don't just let your right
hand spend and forget about don't even
inquire don't even look back
does not depreciate from giving in
charity
and on the flip side one thing which we
or individuals on the day of judgement
maybe like lars thorne himself who's
going to be burning in the hellfire
himself inshallah if he continues at the
pace is that burning in hell fire
yeah
is that they will be saying um
the one thing they'll be regretting is
the fact that they haven't even given
charity we don't want to be like these
individuals
who regret not giving the charity and
days like golden days like this
tonight they'd be little qatar you must
give the charity we must go forward we
must
continue the cause with salaam alaikum
to like
you